so corruption in romania so let's let's
do one by one
corruption go to corruption or driving
corruption
so let's talk about i said corruption is
far more accessible in eastern europe
the reason i said that is because
firstly i live in romania which is a
beautiful country full of beautiful
people i was living there and people
often see me why'd you live in a corrupt
country and my argument was every
country is corrupt if you think america
is not corrupt you are living in a
bubble the world is corrupt england's
corrupt they're all corrupt the eu is
corrupt russia
every country is corrupt i would rather
live in a corrupt country considering
that they're all corrupt
with corruption that's more accessible
to myself than in a country where
they're going to pretend there's law and
order unless you reach a certain level
and then you can access the question it
could be a very simple example if you
are let's say the husband of a senator
for example and you dui let's just make
this a hypothetical this would never
happen this would never happen
you know this kind of stuff around the
greatest country in the world there's no
way fathers of senator husbands of
senators don't drink they don't just do
why well let's imagine you did right in
america you get offered it scot-free but
if you're a single mother or you're a
single parent and you're out there
working a minimum wage job and you're
trying your very very hardest and you
have kids to raise and you get a dui
you're [ __ ] now
i think it's kind of unfair that the
corruption limit in a rich country in
this hypothetical super-rich country
means that people at the absolute elite
can do whatever they want and nobody
else has access i'll give you another
example let's imagine you're in serbia
same scenario you're a senator's
husband and you get caught the dui of
course nothing's going to happen to you
but you're a normal person you get
caught with a dui bro i've had a hard
day at work i know i'm over the limit
i'm sorry here's 50 bucks i'm sorry i'm
just gonna drive straight home all right
cool go home bam accessible corruption
to me that's a more of a appealing
environment to live under than under a
society where they're gonna take a
normal person wreck them under the law
throw their ass in jail and [ __ ]
destroy them and sit there and cry about
law and order law and order law and
order when it's all [ __ ] anyway
there is no law order the threshold for
corruption is too high so for me as a
person you said i'm a chess player if
i'm a chess player and i analyze the
chessboard i have geographical freedom i
have financial freedom i'm going to live
in a society why don't i live in a
society where i have the most possible
moves to make on a chessboard
where would i go i'd go somewhere where
my money can benefit me i don't have
billions
i'm not a senator or some
but i have enough to live in some other
countries and be protected in some
regards that's just an intelligent chess
move
i explained this at length in a video
all that context is all removed i was
talking about speeding fines they take
it they take the misogyny thing they
they talk take something about rape
which is imaginary because i have no
criminal charges against females against
anything in my life ever they put it
together they take in the corruption
from romania they throw that in they
whip it up and they throw it out to the
world and it's [ __ ] it's absolute
[ __ ] what's what's the next one i
said women can't drive so let's stay on
that one real quick i mean i
i can't understand how that's gonna
piss off certain people when you're
explaining corruption and law and order
because where does jealousy and envy
come from if you think about it
jealousy and heavy comes from what
sometimes below usually
it comes from people that no matter what
they do they can never be taped yeah
they can never ever like we were talking
to grant stefan and he says what do you
think about tate what do you think about
everybody that's going to try to do his
affiliate marketing i said go ahead and
do it i said he's not duplicatable yeah
so non-duplicatable people like you are
annoying to people that are i don't know
if you understand what i'm saying
correct
they can't sit there so no matter how
many motivational books they read no
matter how many videos of you they watch
they cannot talk like you and tell the
story
that produces envy and jealousy right
and you can see how someone like this
can be taken out of context saying he
must be a criminal for wanting to go to
a place that doesn't have law and order
absolutely and i understand why they
would say that now what's actually
interesting is booker asked the capital
of romania where i live is statistically
25 times safer than a city like london
it's quite a dangerous place it's it's
the most christian country on earth 99.3
christian the last census there's
churches everywhere it's highly
religious it's a very nice place
it's just a different economic it's just
a different economic bracket there's
nothing to do about romania specifically
if you go to any second world country in
the world with a different economic
bracket the corruption's gonna be more
accessible the price is lower humans are
corrupt every single institution on the
face of the planet that is run by humans
which is currently all of them at some
degree is corrupt all of them whether
it's doctors financial judicial law and
order the monetary system it's all
completely and artly corrupt and to sit
here and believe that any of them are
just and fair i think we've just learned
in the last few years we can see that
even simple things like keeping people
alive even medicine is completely
corrupt from head to toe all of it is so
you have to understand that and then you
have to look at the chess board and go
okay if it's all completely not really
corrupt and i understand that there are
certain people who get to play the game
on cheat mode
do i want to be able to play the game on
cheat mode if i'm going to try and be
the best version of myself well yes i
could possibly do that in nigeria i
could play on cheat mode i could
possibly play on cheat mode in croatia i
could possibly play on cheat mode here
here i have to stick to the rules if i
have to obey the rules of chess against
a person who can move their pieces
however they want i'm going to be
perpetually crushed for attorney so it
makes smart that's just smart business
sense to me to sit there and go you know
what [ __ ] it let's let's change the
board let's move it out let's reset up
the pieces and let's play this way and
this is nothing specific with the
country i live i have absolute respect
for the country i live this is just
human nature this is the nature of
systems and how they work and the nature
of the first world second world third
world this is just how the world works
so i say these things and people want to
sit here and try and they mix it up they
take that and they try and mix it up
with some girl [ __ ] and try and pretend
i'm not talking about basic things like
speeding fights that's really what i'm
talking about and we can have a long
detailed argument about how corrupt
america is but i like to think that most
people the brain understand the kind of
[ __ ] that's going down in america so
america is absolutely corrupt as well
it's just a corrupt world if you enjoyed
this video and you want to watch the
entire podcast click over here and if
you want to be connected with experts
influencers such as kiyosaki tate
connolly parliamentary myself and others
download the app minect where you get a
chance to connect with these folks by
the minute you get to buy the minute or
have face times with them 15 minutes ask
them any questions you might want to
have download the admin act and start
connecting with influencers and experts
today
[Music]